haha the Joe Rogan experience I'd never
seen Breaking Bad ever and I'm on season
five now there's a quarantine I'm like
great you know I'm watching the show it
ends after five seasons dude if a show
goes beyond five seasons it's really
hard to maintain real hard I mean like I
was i watch Dexter after four seasons I
thought the first four seas were [ __ ]
amazing
after the John Lithgow season I was just
like all right I lost it at the John
let's go yeah the John Lithgow I was
like it's just like he would have been
caught he was you know I mean it's like
yeah there was also like there's a
terrible scene where he's choking some
girl in a bathtub and like yeah it's
fake stupid rear naked one no it was a
really good joke oh it was and then he
cut her leg in the bath I'm like this is
it she's not even fighting this is not
people fight you like a wild animal you
would it's just you can't do a show for
like Walking Dead that's it great for
three seasons it was [ __ ] that second
season was amazing great but then it's
like okay I got to a certain point like
this is a [ __ ] terrible show yeah but
but and it's not even it's not even the
show's fault it's the fans fault you
keep watching the [ __ ] it's like yeah
you can't make a show good for 13
seasons and I have like 50 people that
are writing it and a hundred and eighty
people that are working on the set all
those people have jobs you want them to
stay employed so everybody keeps going
and if you quit then everyone's gonna be
mad at you yeah yeah and your heart's
not in it anymore I mean like you know
Sopranos was I think six seasons I think
that's the most you can go maybe yeah
lost lost was another one by the time I
was over I was like what is this shitty
show right they used to be amazing
people forgot about lost lost was a
[ __ ] amazing job on the show yeah I
saw the first few seasons and it was
just you know that show got lost I think
that uh that because it was it didn't
come out it came up before the streaming
[ __ ] you know once this if that came out
like a few years later it would have
been people would still be talking about
it but I feel like people don't because
JJ Abrams became such a big deal and now
they talk about him do another [ __ ]
which is he forgot about it
too many the thing about shows is now
unlike back in the day you can access
all of them so it's not like if you
wanted to watch Starsky and Hutch 20
years ago like Locke where you gonna
find it right right is there a DVD if
stars kind of rich God about that you
can't watch you couldn't watch you
couldn't watch it so once a show was off
the air it was just off the air yeah but
now they just pile up I know they just
keep piling up he's no way you can watch
Handmaid's Tale and Ozark and stranger
thing that's why I give up you got to be
okay with giving up like if it shows not
your bag you got to give up like like
Game of Thrones I watched it for four
season I know you love that [ __ ] show
are you I know but I just you know what
it's not my style of show man why are
you saying I mean awesome no it is
awesome no it is awesome
but it's only awesome it's like Breaking
Bad the reason why I love Breaking Bad
the reason why Sopranos I love it so
much is because there's [ __ ] humor in
it man there's humor in it sometimes
there is zero humor in Game of Thrones
true and I get that that's a style but I
just can't be sucked into something four
five six seasons where nobody trips
where nobody is just like awkward at a
table and they're just talking about
dragons in the most serious [ __ ] way
yeah but there's real dragons back then
I know there were real dragons back then
but still problems there real problems
people were like I'm not waiting and I'm
not saying the show's not great it's
absolutely great and I could never
[ __ ] put that show together in my
life it's all it's awesome but it's just
awesome all the time and I need a break
from it some need humor I and I don't
need something to be rip-roaring ly
funny the whole time as a matter of fact
I don't want it to be what was so funny
the whole time sometimes funny yeah
sometimes fun to watch Ozark Ozark the
first season I saw was killer loved it
did you give up after the first yes
because it was mostly only awesome the
only humor that ever came is because
Jason Bateman is humorous yeah wasn't a
human wasn't a humor wasn't like yeah
but it's so good the only time I can be
involved in a [ __ ] movie or something
with zero humor is if it's with like
Liam Neeson in it and he's just kicking
ass the whole time until the end see I
feel like he's got brittle
he's too old I don't buy him with all
these face punches and something that's
gonna break his hand
I just taken is the [ __ ] to me but yeah
of course he's gonna have to a while
Mike you ain't kicking his ass I know
but also he watchin show with dragon in
it yeah but what's it this is more
realistic he's gonna punch somebody
they're gonna duck catch them on the
forehead his hands shatter it's gonna
blow up like a balloon that's what I
know yeah yeah I know that yeah
[Applause]